[Music]
Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon wildlands may
have a ridiculously long title but it's
shaping up to be one of the best
open-world competitive shooters of 2017
we are fast approaching a release date
in early March so here are ten things
you should know about Tom Clancy's Ghost
Recon wildlands let's start with the
story you play as part of a four-person
team known as the ghost which is a
secretive elite unit in the US Army
track you are sent to Bolivia to take
down the Santa Blanca drug cartel and
potentially uncover links to the
government you and your team must adapt
to your surroundings and decide when
it's the right time to running like a
madman to snipe from afar or attempt to
covert stealthy approach for each
mission wildlands brings together
elements from three Ubisoft games Ghost
Recon Future Soldier watchdogs and the
division so if you're a fan of the
original Ghost Recon or if you've
enjoyed teaming up with friends in the
decision I'll simply love the open world
of watchdogs this could be the ultimate
amalgam of all three titles speaking of
open world as you probably expect
wildlands will utilize a day/night cycle
in addition to dynamic weather systems
making stealth options a lot easier at
night fully kitted up with night-vision
goggles or alternately wait for a
rainstorm and take out the guards ignore
visibility the world is seemingly your
oyster no single customization is a huge
part of Ghost Recon wildlands and shares
a striking resemblance with the division
if you want your character to wear a
certain piece of apparel or have the
perfect haircut more often than not you
can find it so I'll be making a six-foot
chunky guy with a ginger mohawk so keep
an eye out for me another similarity to
the division and many other Ubisoft
games is a progression system which
allows you to earn experience and
variety of ways from story missions to
random events everything after your
character's development and boost your
weapon damage and defensive abilities
attack let's get one thing straight this
is a cooperative game if you want this
game for a single-player experience you
will miss out on what Ubisoft are trying
to achieve the three spots on your team
will be filled by AI which cannot plan
and execute orders like your best mates
so tell Dave Nigel and Tiffany about
this game and decide together if it's
worth
or not vehicles will play a huge part in
Ghost Recon wildlands as the map is huge
your team will become divided at times
so a helicopter or a fast car will make
things a lot easier in that respect it
plays similarly to the heist in GTA
where each character has a job to do the
AI has received an impressive
improvement on previous Ghost Recon
games the guards now utilize a shift
pattern and become fatigued at the end
of their shift this once again impacts
your approach to each mission as you
could take out lethargic guards much
easier by waiting for the right moment
to strike finally depending on when
you're watching this video you can sign
up for the beta right now
I'll throw the link in the description
below so that's how Tom Clancy's Ghost
Recon wildlands is shaping up what do
you think about this will you be picking
it up please let us know below
I am Adam from Playstation grenade and
if you're new to our channel please
stick around and check out some other
videos thanks for your time I'll see you
next time
[Music]
you